>>> DR. ROBERT REDFIELD, A
FORMER CDC DIRECTOR, IS SPEAKING
OUT FOR THE FIRST TIME SAYING
PUBLICLY WHERE HE BELIEVES THE
CORONAVIRUS THAT CAUSED THE
PANDEMIC CAME FROM.
THESE EXTRAORDINARY COMMENTS
COME IN A CNN DOCUMENTARY AIRING
THIS WEEKEND.
DR. SANJAY GUPTA JOINS US NOW.
DR. REDFIELD SAYS HE'S GIVING
HIS OPINION, BUT I THINK YOU'RE
ABOUT TO BREAK SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT NEWS HERE.
>> YEAH, THIS WAS EXTRAORDINARY,
JOHN.
FOR CERTAIN.
HE IS THE FORMER CDC DIRECTOR.
HE SPENT HIS ENTIRE CAREER AS A
VIROLOGIST.
I INTERVIEWED ALL SIX OF THESE
DOCTORS IN THE FORM OF AN
AUTOPSY.
REALLY TO METICULOUSLY DISSECT
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
REALLY NO PREAGENDA.
DR. REDFIELD WHEN WE SAT DOWN TO
TALK, HE WANTED TO START AT THE
BEGINNING.
THE ORIGINS OF THIS VIRUS.
WHAT HE BELIEVED ACTUALLY
TRANSPIRED.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IF I WAS TO GUESS, THIS VIRUS
STARTED TRANSMITTING SOMEWHERE
IN SEPTEMBER, OCTOBER IN WUHAN.
>> SEPTEMBER, OCTOBER?
>> THAT'S MY OWN VIEW.
IT'S ONLY AN OPINION.
I'M ALLOWED TO HAVE OPINIONS
NOW.
I'M OF THE POINT OF VIEW THAT I
STILL THINK THE MOST LIKELY
IDOLOGY OF THIS PATHOLOGY IN
WUHAN WAS FROM A LABORATORY.
ESCAPED.
OTHER PEOPLE DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
THAT'S FINE.
SCIENCE WILL EVENTUALLY FIGURE
IT OUT.
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL FOR RESPIRATORY
PATHOGENS THAT ARE BEING WORKED
ON IN A LABORATORY TO INFECT THE
LABORATORY WORKER.
>> IT'S ALSO NOT UNUSUAL FOR
THAT TYPE OF RESEARCH TO BE
OCCURRING IN WUHAN.
THE CITY IS A WIDELY KNOWN
CENTER FOR VIRAL STUDIES IN
CHINA, INCLUDING THE WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY, WHICH HAS
EXPERIMENTED EXTENSIVELY WITH
BAT CORONAVIRUSES.
>> IT'S A REMARKABLE
CONVERSATION.
I FEEL LIKE WE'RE HAVING HERE.
BECAUSE YOU ARE THE FORMER CDC
DIRECTOR, AND YOU WERE THE
DIRECTOR AT THE TIME THIS WAS
ALL HAPPENING.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME, THE
FORMER CDC DIRECTOR IS STATING
PUBLICLY THAT HE BELIEVES THIS
PANDEMIC STARTED MONTHS EARLIER
THAN WE KNEW.
AND THAT IT ORIGINATED, NOT AT A
WET MARKET, BUT INSIDE A LAB IN
CHINA.
>> THESE ARE TWO SIGNIFICANT
THINGS TO SAY.
>> THAT'S NOT IMPLYING ANY
INTENTIONALITY.
IT'S MY OPINION, RIGHT?
BUT I AM A VIROLOGIST.
I HAVE SPENT MY LIFE IN
VIROLOGY.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THIS SOMEHOW
CAME FROM A BAT TO A HUMAN AND
AT THAT MOMENT IN TIME, THE
VIRUS CAME TO THE HUMAN, BECAME
ONE OF THE MOST INFECTIOUS
VIRUSES THAT WE KNOW IN HUMANITY
FOR HUMAN-TO-HUMAN TRANSMISSION.
NORMALLY IT TAKES AWHILE FOR IT
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BECOME MORE
AND MORE EFFICIENT IN HUMAN TO
HUMAN TRANSMISSION.
I JUST DON'T THINK THIS MAKES
BIOLOGICAL SENSE.
>> SO IN THE LAB, DO YOU THINK
THAT PROCESS OF BECOMING MORE
EFFICIENT WAS HAPPENING?
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE SUGGESTING?
>> LET'S JUST SAY, I HAVE
CORONAVIRUS AND I'M WORKING ON
IT.
MOST OF US IN THE LAB ARE TRYING
TO GROW VIRUS.
WE TRY TO MAKE IT GROW BETTER
AND BETTER AND BETTER AND BETTER
SO WE CAN DO EXPERIMENTS AND
FIGURE BOUGHT IT.
THAT'S THE WAY I PUT IT
TOGETHER.
>> IT'S A PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY
CONVERSATION.
AND A LITTLE GLIMPSE OF WHAT WE
REVEALED SORT OF WITHIN THESE
COUPLE OF HOURS.
I SHOULD POINT OUT, THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION CALLS THE
LAB LEAK THEORY UNLIKELY.
AND CHINESE OFFICIALS HAVE
STARTED INCREASINGLY POINTING TO
A MULTIPLE ORIGIN THEORY SAYING
THAT THIS PANDEMIC MAY HAVE
STARTED IN MULTIPLE PLACES, EVEN
AROUND THE WORLD, INCLUDING U.S.
MILITARY LABS.
THAT'S UNSUBSTANTIATED, BUT
THAT'S SORT OF THE BACK AND
FORTH HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW, A YEAR
LATER, EXACTLY HOW THIS PANDEMIC
STARTED.
>> HE'S THE FORMER CDC DIRECTOR.
SO WHEN HE SAYS IT'S JUST HIS
OPINION, IT'S NOT JUST AN
OPINION.
THE FORMER CDC DIRECTOR SEES
THINGS AND KNOWS THINGS THE REST
OF US DON'T SEE --
>> LIFE LONG EXPERTISE.
>> WHEN HE WAS IN THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT SEEING THINGS THAT
THE REST OF US AREN'T ENTITLED
TO.
HOW MUCH OF JUST AN OPINION CAN
IT BE?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
HE'S TALKING TO PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND, NOT JUST AS COUNTERPARTS
OF THE CHINA CDC, BUT WE HAVE
INVESTIGATORS ON THE GROUND IN
VARIOUS COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD, INCLUDING CHINA.
IF YOU LOOK EVEN AT OUR
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE SORT
OF STRATEGIES IN THE UNITED
STATES, IT'S MEDICAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH.
BUT IT'S ALSO INTELLIGENCE
GATHERING.
SO WHEN WE'RE SITTING DOWN AND
TALKING TO ALL THESE PEOPLE,
WE'RE GIVING A SORT OF OVERALL
PICTURE, I THINK, FOR THE FIRST
TIME OF WHAT THEY KNEW, WHAT
THEY KNEW AT WHAT TIME, AND HOW
THEY WERE SORT OF PIECING THAT
TOGETHER.
SO IT'S REALLY -- AND IT'S NOT
JUST INTRIGUE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW HOW THIS
STARTED IF YOU ARE GOING TO BEST
PREPARE FOR A POSSIBLE FUTURE
PANDEMIC.
TO GO AND -- FROM AN ANIMAL TO A
HUMAN AND SUDDENLY BECOME ONE OF
THE MOST INFECTIOUS PATHOGENS
WE'VE EVER SEEN IN HUMANITY
SIMPLY DOESN'T HAPPEN VERY
OFTEN.
THAT'S THE POINT DR. REDFIELD
WAS TRYING TO MAKE.
>> SANJAY GUPTA, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
AND IT DOES SOUND LIKE SOMETHING
WE NEED TO DISCUSS MORE.
LET'S DO THAT RIGHT NOW, JOHN.
LET'S BRING IN CNN POLITICAL
ANALYST JOSH ROGIN.
HE'S DONE A LOT OF REPORTING ON
THE ORIGIN OF COVID-19.
THE AUTHOR OF "CHAOS UNDER
HEAVEN: AMERICA, CHINA AND THE
BATTLE FOR THE 21st CENTURY."
JOSH, YOU'VE DONE REPORTING ON
THE ORIGINS.
YOU -- WE'VE HAD THESE
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU.
TELL US THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
HEARING DR. REDFIELD, FORMER
DIRECTOR, SAY THIS.
THAT'S WHAT HE THINKS, IT CAME
FROM A LAB.
>> YOU KNOW, MY INITIAL
REACTION, ALISYN, IS, WOW.
STUNNING.
GROUND-BREAKING.
REALLY NARRATIVE-CHANGING
CONVERSATION THAT SANJAY GUPTA
HAD WITH ROBERT REDFIELD FOR A
COUPLE OF IMPORTANT REASONS.
ONE IS AS YOU MENTIONED, HE IS
NOT ANY SCHMO -- JOE-SCHMO
SCIENTIST.
HE WAS THE HEAD OF THE CDC, A
VIROLOGIST AND HE'S MAKING TWO
VERY SHOCKING ALLEGATIONS.
ONE IS THAT THE VIRUS STARTED IN
SEPTEMBER OR OCTOBER, ACCORDING
TO HIS OPINION, WHICH IMPLIES
THAT THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT HID
IT FOR SEVERAL MONTHS.
AND TWO, THAT HE BELIEVES NOT
JUST BASED ON, YOU KNOW,
SUPPOSITION BUT BASED ON THE WAY
THE VIRUS EMERGED, IN HIS
PROFESSIONAL ANALYSIS OF THE WAY
IT ACTED, THAT IT WAS TOO STRONG
AND TOO ADVANCED TO HAVE COME
FROM NATURE.
AND HE'S REFERRING TO THE
RESEARCH AT THE WUHAN INSTITUTE
OF VIROLOGY.
NOW THAT MATCHES THE INFORMATION
THAT CAME OUT OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, AND WAS
CONFIRMED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO SOME DEGREE
WHEN THEY CAME IN AND CHECKED
THE U.S. INTELLIGENCE WORK.
SO IT'S NOT JUST ROBERT
REDFIELD'S OPINION.
THERE'S A GROWING BODY OF
EVIDENCE THAT POINTS TO THIS LAB
ACCIDENT THEORY.
WHILE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED, WE CAN'T SAY WE KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED, THIS MAKES IT
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THERE'S MORE INVESTIGATION AND
THAT WE REGARD THE ONGOING
INVESTIGATION, FRANKLY, BY THE
W.H.O. AND CHINESE SCIENTISTS AS
NOT THE END OF THE INQUIRY HERE
BECAUSE, AS YOU NOTED, THEY ARE
POO-POOING THIS THEORY AGAIN.
>> REDFIELD SAYS IT'S JUST HIS
OPINION, BUT HE'S NOT JUST ANY
GUY OR ANY JOE-SCHMO AS YOU
SAID.
DON'T WE NEED TO SEE THE
EVIDENCE, HOW THIS OPINION OF
HIS AND THEN THE CLAIMS MADE BY
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
VERIFIED TO AN EXTENT BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WE NEED TO
SEE THE EVIDENCE OF ALL OF THIS.
>> WE NEED TO SEE THE EVIDENCE
ON THE CHINESE SIDE AND U.S.
SIDE.
ROBERT REDFIELD, WHEN HE WAS CDC
DIRECTOR, HE WAS NOT A -- TREAT
LEAD BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
HE HAS NO INCENTIVE, NO
MOTIVATION TO BAIL THEM OUT OR
TO SUPPORT THEIR THEORY FOR
THEIR SAKE.
HE'S DOING THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
WHAT HE REALLY BELIEVES, AND
IT'S BASED ON WHAT HE SAW WHEN
HE WAS INSIDE THE GOVERNMENT.
SO THE EASIEST THING TO DO IS
FOR THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
TO RELEASE PUBLICLY THE
INTELLIGENCE THAT THEY HAVE BUT
THE ONLY REAL WAY TO CRACK THIS
IS FOR THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT TO
HAND OVER THE DATA OF THE EARLY
CASES, ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE IN THE LAB.
WHAT THEY SAY IS, OH, THE LAB
DIDN'T HAVE THE VIRUS, SO THAT'S
THAT.
BUT WHAT ROBERT REDFIELD IS
SAYING IS WE CAN'T TAKE THAT AT
FACE VALUE.
WE'LL NEED AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION, BUT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION COULD ALSO BE
MORE TRANSPARENT AS WELL.
>> EVEN IF THERE'S AN
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION, WOULD
CHINA BE INCLINED TO HAND OVER
WHATEVER DOCUMENTATION THEY HAVE
ABOUT WHAT THEY WERE DOING IN
THE LAB?
NUMBER ONE.
AND NUMBER TWO, WHY DOESN'T THE
W.H.O. SEEM TO BE ON THE SAME
PAGE WITH DR. REDFIELD?
>> RIGHT.
WELL, IN YOUR FIRST QUESTION,
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT HAS HAD
OVER A YEAR TO HAND OVER THE
DATA, AND THEY'VE DONE QUITE THE
OPPOSITE.
THEY'VE HIT THE DATE.
THERE ARE ALLEGATIONS THEY'VE
MANIPULATED THE DATA.
THEY JAILED THE JOURNALISTS,
SILENCED THE SCIENTISTS.
THAT'S A PATTERN OF OBFUSCATION
AND COVER-UP PRETTY MUCH
UNDENIAL AT THIS POINT.
THAT'S A PROBLEM THAT I DON'T
THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SOLVE.
AND THAT'S UNFORTUNATE.
AND THE W.H.O. TEAM, WHICH I'M
SURE IS FULL OF A LOT OF
WELL-MEANING PEOPLE, SIMPLY
DOESN'T HAVE THE ACCESS THAT
THEY NEED.
SOME OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
W.H.O. INVESTIGATIVE TEAM HAVE
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST.
AND THEIR STATEMENTS SO FAR SHOW
THEY'RE NOT REALLY LOOKING INTO
THE LAB ACCIDENT THEORY AT ALL
BECAUSE THEY DON'T BELIEVE IT TO
BE TRUE.
THEY DON'T WANT IT TO BE TRUE.
WE SHOULDN'T IGNORE THE W.H.O.
INVESTIGATION, BUT IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE THE END ALL, BE ALL
OF WHAT WE KNOW.
IT JUST CAN'T BE.
AS YOU HEARD, THE HEAD OF THE
CDC DURING THE TIME OF THE
OUTBREAK SAYS THE W.H.O.
INVESTIGATION IS ON THE WRONG
TRACK.
>> JOSH ROGIN, SO GOOD TO GET
YOUR REPORTING AND EXPERTISE
INTO THIS.
>> CAN'T WAIT FOR THE SPECIAL.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE -- DON'T
MISS THIS UNPRECEDENTED EVENT
WITH DR. SANJAY GUPTA WHEN THE
MEDICAL LEADERS OF THE WAR ON
COVID BREAK THEIR SILENCE.
WATCH THE CNN SPECIAL "COVID
WAR: T